thanks guys yes we are with Sebastian
borduja the minister of digitalization
here in the Romanian government
Sebastian first of all welcome to the
show Welcome to the super bachelor's
classic tell us about your first
impressions of the tournament I love the
energy I think it's absolutely wonderful
everybody's coming together and we're
very proud and honored to host this
amazing event in Bucharest again and I
saw a lot of smiling faces a lot of
anticipation before this important day I
think it's the final day yes and so the
championship round Championship round
and I was very honored to to do the
first move which I've done last year as
well so thank you for having me back
tell us a bit about your work as the
minister of digitalization
well it's very exciting I like to say
that I'm the luckiest minister of the
whole government I'm certainly the
youngest I'm 39 almost but I'm the
luckiest because I often interact with
the smartest people that Romania has uh
that are researchers innovators experts
in digital transformation in itnc
generally the country has amazing Minds
in I.T I think we're famous not just for
uh gymnastics and and Dracula and
vampires but also for a very smart I.T
people and every day I interact with
them were basically in the middle of a
digital Revolution as I like to call it
and we're taking our government digital
we're providing more and more Public
Services entirely in the digital
environment as well as helping to
educate the young people in in what it
means to to be in the new digital
economy and be competitive we had our
own digital Revolution as well in 97
when Gary Casper lost his match against
uh deep blue at the beginning we were a
bit afraid to embrace this new
technology But as time of passed we
started welcoming it do you see any
similarities between our story and your
story in the real world yeah I mean I
think you know playing chess it opens up
your mind and you see new possibilities
all the time you have to adapt
dynamically it's the world we live in
and certainly you see the pace of
technological change has never been
faster there's a theory called the the
knowledge curve and apparently uh you
know around 1945 our the knowledge that
Humanity had doubled every 25 years I
think it was today it doubles every 12
hours so you know with the event of AI
and virtual reality and all the new
tools that that are now available really
to anybody in the world
just the pace of change is is tremendous
and do you see the Romanians embracing
this change as well I do uh and I'm very
happy about it because I think that you
cannot Advance your economy your country
unless you take everybody with you
there's something called the digital gap
which is a risk in that those who are
less fortunate uh poorer have less
access to education and also have less
access to technology so the risk in this
process is that they could just get left
further behind that inequality grows so
you know special measures are needed and
policies to ensure that those who don't
have
all the opportunities that that other
members of society have have access to
these programs to digital skills and in
fact I think it can be a way for them to
catch up faster and it can be a way for
a country like Romania to catch up
faster to Western Europe and to the
United States Sebastian I think you're
doing great work thank you very much for
joining us and all deciding to be here
and good luck to all those competing
thank you guys back to you thank you
Sebastian